[Music]
hi there my name is Cameron and I am the
guy behind motion science and I have
decided to put together this free
training series on what I'm calling idea
to execution I get asked all the time
how do you get from an idea that a
client gives you or an idea that you've
got in your mind how do you get that to
the design phase and to the emotion
phase and finally I'd like to a finished
piece that you're proud of so I get
asked that so many times I decided
Hamlet put together a free training
series and show you how I do this so I
want to jump right into this I don't
want to waste any time on this I want to
just get to the meat of this I'm gonna
spread this out over several videos
because it is a lot of content but I
hope you enjoy this series so like I
said Who am I I'm Cameron I'm the guy
behind motion science and I started
motion science several years ago because
I saw a void in the training area of
motion design that wasn't quite being
filled there's a lot of great resources
out there but what I was doing as a
motion designer I wasn't seeing a lot of
that being taught so that's why I'm here
that's what I'm teaching through motion
science and you know just a little give
a little background on Who I am I never
went to art school I never studied art
in you know an early education and high
school nothing like that I never took a
drawing class I can't draw I can draw
digitally on a computer I can't draw by
pencil and paper I always have a lot of
respect for those guys that can do that
kind of stuff so I never took a design
class I never took a photography class I
always had kind of a knack for making
short films I was always really into it
and I won't point I wanted to be a
director but um back in the day when
motion graphics kind of burst onto the
scene I was working for a TV station
really small TV station and I saw After
Effects which was called cosa back then
and it really grabbed my attention and
so I started teaching myself everything
I could about After Effects so I became
an animator first which I wouldn't
necessarily suggest I see that a lot of
today a lot of motion designers they
know
animate really well but they don't know
how to design okay and as a motion
designer we should all know some aspects
of design right you have to understand
what makes something look good it so
it's great if you can make it move
really well but we should also
understand how to design it so I just
taught myself how to design one day I
was hired by a company kind of a
high-profile company and they asked me
if I could design some style frames I
was scared to death to do it um but I I
created them they were super impressed
and before you knew it I was making more
and more designs so it's taken me a long
time to learn how to become a motion
designer but I want to show you what
I've learned because I'd like I said I
never went to art school and now I'm
teaching people how to create motion
design at a high level and the feedback
I've gotten over the years has been
incredible so I know I'm doing something
right
so my methods aren't necessarily like I
said taught in school in a traditional
sense but they work right and I continue
to get hired for freelance work motion
design work for high-profile clients so
let's start an exercise so this first
video I've told you enough about me I
know that a lot of you have experienced
problems where you can't get ideas into
executions to final finished pieces so
that's why I'm going to show you so
let's just dive right in so when you
work with a client a lot of times you
can get a lot of different creative
briefs okay sometimes the client will
send you a creative brief that has a lot
of detailed information it could be
pages and pages of information from
colors to typography to what you should
be using to tons and tons of reference
sometimes you'll get one sentence
sometimes you'll get one page so what
I'm gonna do with this exercise is I'm
gonna give you one page okay and this is
a creative brief for a client for a TV
show called red robots so right here we
have red robot creative brief okay and
deliverable request from the client they
want a title's design slash motion test
they want it to be under ten seconds in
length sixteen by nine format 24 frames
per second use three actor names which
are Nina gates Gina black and Toby Sykes
so that's the initial deliverable
request that the client is asking for us
you don't know what a motion test is
it's just where a client's looking for
ideas for ways to take a take it
directions to take a project in so a
motion test is never really finalized
it's just a small piece
it gives creative directors and
companies ideas of where they can go
with what they're looking for so that's
what we're gonna create it's got me
under 10 seconds in length 6 to my 9 24
frames per second and 3 actor names the
concept from the client says red robot
is a television series that takes place
in a not so distant utopian future with
ties to the ancient past
so that concept line is a little bit
unknown I guess you could say it's it's
a little bit intriguing excuse me
because there's not a lot of information
there likes it like I said sometimes a
client will give you a ton of
information here for the concept other
times it could be one sentence or it
could be a couple words you never know
so this is very open to interpretation
which again a lot of times with motion
tests things are open to interpretation
as a designer if you give a creative
brief like this to let's say five or six
motion designers you're gonna come get
five or six totally different pieces
back from each of those designers
because this their take on what the
client is looking for so that's what's
so great about motion tests okay items
to consider sacred geometry if you don't
know what that is we'll take a look at
in just a second symmetry distressed
texture glitch provided music tracks so
the clients providing us a music track
to base the song and then texture and
then for tone mood and style it's
futuristic glitchy dark and moody which
I love analog and duo color palette okay
so when we get a creative brief like
this a lot of times the client will also
send us different pieces to mess around
with right to explore so the first thing
we're look at here is we are going to
look at the or listen to the music track
because right here we saw provided music
track so let's just play this back it up
[Music]
[Music]
okay I'm gonna go ahead and stop it
there that's a minute so three two to
three minute song here so we'd only
listen to all that you get the idea okay
it's it's called synth wait cyberpunk
it's dark and moody for sure futuristic
for sure
it's got an analogue feel to it I can I
can hear texture in the music right
distressed glitchyness all that great
stuff so this is a music track provided
to us from the client it's awesome I
love it okay so we've we've taken a look
at the creative brief we've listened the
music track so now let me show you what
we're actually going to create it's
gonna be something along these lines
[Music]
I'll play it one more time okay so if
you want to learn how to get from this
critter brief to this finest finished
piece I'm by you to stick around for the
next several videos and we're going to
create this piece so how would I create
this where do I start right well I start
I go always go back to the creative
brief and I start really just looking at
this and kind of dissecting it now
without diving too deep into these into
this without taking up hours and hours
of your time to create this stuff I'm
gonna move kind of fast and I'm gonna
kind of you know briefly go over some of
these things and not really dive into
all them because we don't have a lot of
time to do this so what I would do next
is I would study this creative brief and
then I would go into something like
Pinterest okay I've got a motion science
Pinterest page that's got tons and tons
of boards okay and in these boards I've
divided them into different categories
things like digital texture things like
glitch things like retro geometry
science design okay now something like
this project you know the retro stuffs
not going to work so well so I'm gonna
go ahead and close that out this isn't
necessarily what I'm looking for but
just to give you an idea if I was to go
back into my motion science account here
and look at my boards I've got a lot of
boards here right you can see typography
digital texture retro colored studio
logos it goes on and on and on
vitam all up in two different boards and
I've got a lot of hidden boards as well
that I keep for myself so how I would do
is I would start looking for inspiration
right based on the creative brief I
would start kind of pulling assets and
saying okay what do I like about this
particular piece like for example this
piece right here this is a this is a Jif
right so this is really interesting
digital texture I like the the noise
that's going on I like the different
chromatic aberration that's happening in
the image splitting apart and glitching
out it's really really interesting and I
really look at these examples and I say
okay well what what about it is what why
do i fleck it's a strong piece you know
and I like I just told you it's the
noise it's the chromatic aberration it's
the image splitting apart and then maybe
I go into an image like this and I say
what I love about this well I love all
of the displacement mapping that's going
on I love the digital texture that I see
and I love the way that it's on the
sides it's very narrow digital texture
but in the center it's a very wide
digital texture let me jump another
board so glitch here's a glitch board
here what I love about this I love on
this example the use of color with
glitch right again we've got chromatic
aberration we've got image splitting
apart with the greens and the Reds
splitting apart we've got greens or
blues splitting off of the Reds here so
it's creating like this blue halo effect
really strong composition as well with
the shape over the statue here now let
me jump into another board here that's
the main board
okay geometry so again this is an image
that was highly inspirational to me when
I started creating this project and that
this image is based on sacred geometry
and symmetry okay we just looked at
glitch we looked at some distressed
texture we obviously listen to the music
track but sacred geometry and symmetry
are images like this this is what they
mean to me as a designer okay and you
can see I've got this geometry board
here and it's got all types of just
really interesting geometry going on and
I just absolutely love this stuff
here's one for science design against a
lot of symmetry going on if you look
let's pull this one up
you know how the the lines just repeat
themselves and create this perfect
symmetry up and down so really really
great stuff this is where I would start
okay and I start pulling references I
start pulling assets and looking at
design and in motion and seeing what
really stands out to me okay so after
I've got that the next step I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna find an image that is going
to be very inspirational to me to start
designing some pieces so that's we're
gonna do next we're gonna jump into
After Effects here and inside of After
Effects we want to create a new
composition I'm gonna make it 200 frames
long because this needs to be between 6
and 10 seconds 200 frames is plenty it's
24 frames a second 1920 by 1080 and
we're gonna call this red robots so
there's going to be our main composition
okay so the next thing I'm gonna do and
this is how I like to work and there's
there's so many different ways you can
do this but this is the process I'm
going to use for this is I'm going to
actually design inside of After Effects
I prefer to design inside of After
Effects it's much easier to me than
designing inside of Photoshop because
there's I have a lot more effects and
plugins and if I can keep it here in
After Effects why not design it here
because once I'm ready to put into
motion it's all here ready to go so
let's just drag in this music track I've
got it pulled in here and I'm just going
to go ahead and hit ll on my keyboard
and start finding an end point that I
want to start working with okay so I
know that I've listened to this and I
like it around 987 frames into this so
if I hit the period on my keypad I'll be
like hear this
[Music]
so I'm going to stop it about here about
160 frames into it
[Music]
yes that works for me so if I was to
pull up my calculator here really
quickly and I say if I'm 160 frames in
and I divide that by 24 frames a second
I'm at just over six and a half seconds
long so I'm gonna back this up just a
little bit so it sounds a little more
pleasant to me so let's try this
[Music]
yeah so that sounds good I'm gonna lock
that layer there we go okay so now I've
got the music in here I need to actually
set some edit points I like to just
create some very simple edit points of
where I want my scenes to be so I'm
gonna hit so you hear that snare happen
right there so I'm gonna hit shift 1 to
create a marker I want something
happened probably right here I also want
something to happen here on this next
snare so when I hit shift 3
[Music]
something right there
and right there so now if I play it back
and I look at these markers and imagine
a scene happening during these times I
think it'll work and then right here is
actually scene 6 and this is just my
simple cut to black so I'm gonna say cut
to black and we're gonna make this pure
black there and I'm going to set my end
point there and I can lock this layer
because we go black right here and we're
good to go on this one we don't here on
number 2 we don't hear a snare right we
don't hear like a hit but I also hear
some music going on there that I want to
see something happening so that's what I
do so now I've got a very rough outline
of where I want things to happen at so
at this point I'm gonna start designing
elements and just kind of dropping them
in next I'm gonna do is I'm gonna create
a new composition and I'm gonna make
this I'm gonna get a square composition
2000 by 2000 and it doesn't need to be
the full length let's just make it let's
make it 40 us let's make it an even
number let's make it 60 okay and we're
actually gonna call this sacred geo
imported an illustrator file that I
really like for this example as
reference okay so I'm gonna you can't
see anything here it's black so I'm
going to say let's go to channel and all
the channel inverts and there we go
there it is so I'm gonna go ahead and
scale it up so I can see it and I am
going to turn on my grid and I need to
set my grid to
something like 500 see how that looks
let's go actually even smaller let's go
into 250 perfect so now I want to do is
I want to scale this guy up so he kind
of lines up with these points throughout
here so maybe somewhere in here maybe
actually just go up to 500 something
like this and you can see by looking at
this image it's not totally square right
like the center point here is off the
center point appears off to the side so
that's okay we're just gonna use this as
a reference and I'm gonna start
recreating this inside of After Effects
the reason I'm doing this is if I opened
this up inside of Illustrator these are
not strokes these are our fills okay and
I want to be able to take something like
a trim path and just do a simple trim on
it and make the lines just kind of draw
on their own way and I can't do that
with fills so how we're going to just
we're going to go ahead and just create
a new shape layer okay and before I get
too far I'm gonna go ahead and drop the
transparency of this reference down
something like 20% and then we'll go
ahead and lock it there okay so this
first shape layer I want to create the
circles so I'm just gonna set the select
circle double click and there it is it's
really big and open up the ellipse here
and I'm going to drop this down to 250
pixels and there you can see so this is
perfectly centered and like I said you
can see that the reference is not quite
so centered in its design okay so next
we are going to select the ellipse go to
add and we're in a set repeater and
there we go we're gonna set this to
maybe two copies here so we've got two
copies transformer feeder and I'm going
to go let's say 250
[Music]
okay now 250 let's go 500 and there we
go so because we sew up the grids to be
250 pixels this is a 2,000 by 2,000
composition pretty much I'm trying to
stay in a 250 pixel to 500 pixel
movement to keep everything very uniform
so 500 pixels kind of lines this guy up
here with these works good enough for me
for right now let's go ahead and add a
second repeater here and to this one I'm
going to say let's make this six copies
and we don't want the position to be
changed here so when to go back to zero
there and I'm going to turn the rotation
up to about 60 perfect there we go that
looks really good okay I like that
so that is going to be called our
circles I'll go ahead and close that up
and to get these circles to really line
up with these guys here all I have to do
is hit R for rotation and I just have to
rotate these guys something like so so
now I've got the ones at the top and the
bottom perfectly lined up with these
grid points these are looking pretty
good as well close that I'm gonna make
another new shape layer and I'm going to
double click the circle again and to
this one I'm going to bring down the
size to something ever I said I want to
work with the 250 to 500 pixel range so
if we do 1250 pixels here
perfect see how easily it lines up with
the outside of these circles so that's
perfect we're gonna call this big circle
and let's do another shape layer and
we're I call this triangles
and for this one to make a triangle I'll
get to do is go to the star tool and
we'll double click that star tool and
we'll open up the poly star and we'll
say hey I don't want you to be a 5-point
star once you'd be a 3-point star which
is a triangle and I'm going to bring the
inner radius down to 250 and outer
radius to 500 there we go perfect let's
set a repeater here and let's just
rotate this repeater let's turn off
position and that is one thing that
drives me crazy is that it always
whenever you add a repeater it it
defaults to offsets position by a
hundred which can throw people off so
there we go it looks awesome and then
let's create a inside the strangle let's
just create another poly star and if I
can just hit command-d it's going to
duplicate it and I'm going to turn off
this repeater and all I'm going to do
with this poly star is just rotate it
let's see here let's do rotation 180
degrees and allied let's go ahead and
scale it by 50% and there we go there's
our inner triangle perfect and let's go
to a new shape layer again and let's
call these let's call them polygons and
for the polygon we're going to go up
here to the polygon tool and
double-click and to this one let's make
it
six-pointed and let's go ahead and bring
down the outer radius here and you know
if we go to 500 perfect and we're gonna
repeat this one and if the repeater it's
just gonna be two coffees and we're
gonna scale down this second copy here
and take the position zero scale to 50%
perfect real close all we have left now
is these inner lines or these these
lines that cross each other and that's
really simple we're going to create one
more shape layer and we will call these
lines and the lines are a star so we'll
double click there and we will go in and
we will say okay we want this to be six
points inter radius should be zero and
as we do that you can see they all draw
in it collapse on themselves now we've
got these lines and we are going to
bring the outer radius down to bellow
what 500 and you can see the advantage
here of working with even numbers right
so now if I turn off the reference we've
got this really cool sacred geometry to
work with based on the creative brief
and the inspiration we pulled from
Pinterest okay so I want to work with
one other piece of sacred geometry I
don't want to use just this one element
throughout the entire piece it get a
little too repetitive so I think it'd be
interesting to use one other piece and
for that I'm gonna create another new
composition and it's the same thing and
we'll call this sacred go2 there it is
okay and we're gonna make this a little
bit differently so we're gonna jump in
Illustrator here and I've got this
geometry that I pulled in from somewhere
off of the web I don't remember exactly
where I got
but I found it and I really liked it
again the same problem is it's a fill
right these are filled they're not
there's no strokes going on here so a
stroke the reason I want to use that is
for trim pass which I'll get into in the
next video and you'll see why but what I
like to do for examples like this if I
have something like this shape and I
want to use in After Effects I love to
use overlord okay and this is a this is
a almost set free it's not free it's a
script on a II scripts comm it's really
awesome and it helps to push illustrator
shapes into After Effects there's other
things you can do with it but it's
mostly what I use it for so I'm gonna go
to my window extensions load up overlord
I've noticed that I have to have this
window open for this to work go back and
illustrator and I just make sure I
select everything and I'd simply click
this button push selection to AE and
boom there it is it's inside of a E but
you're gonna scale it up a little bit
here so there's my second sacred Geo and
you can see how quickly I brought this
guy in here but again the next video
we're going to talk about animating and
things like that
this one's just about the design aspect
so what I want to do here I also want to
add some type pogrom I'm just kind of
laying out I've got my general scene
outline here I've got my music in I'm
going to lay out some elements kind of
bring them in here and and just kind of
give a very rough assemble going on so
to do that I'm going to bring in sacred
go1 and I'm gonna probably make sicker
go1 be the second scene here and I'm
just going to shorten this and kind of
bring like that okay perfect so sacred
go2
will be our opening scene and i'm gonna
bring that in here like so
so there are sacred geo - there's sacred
go1 / sacred go1 I want to put some
typography so I'm just going to take my
selection tool and I'm going to use a
typeface called stargaze there's a lot
of typefaces as you know in the world
today so many of them this is one I just
found off of a free site like 1001 fonts
com
or dafont.com and I'm just gonna use
this font I found that it works very
well for what I'm trying to do here you
saw it in the example so I'm actually
just going to jump back into my creative
brief and say okay the first name is
Nina gates so right here will be Nina
gates okay doesn't have to be perfect
just kind of dropping it in here and
just getting a very rough outline
because this is called red robot I'm
going to make this a deep red something
like here did that be perfect great
there we go
and I'm going to shorten her name so
she's just in this scene here I'm going
to hit command D to duplicate and go to
the next scene actually I talked about
how this scene would actually continue
to scene two number three here right
here we're number two is if you remember
if you go back in the video I talked
about something happening here it's the
same scene but I want some additional
movement to happen here so moving the
next scene here this is scene three okay
we've got Nina so the next name when you
pull up here is Gina black Gina black
and like I said I'm sorry if I'm going
too fast for you here but I'm trying to
put in a lot information in these videos
and I don't want to spend too much time
I know we have all got very limited
schedules there's that one we hit
command-d again duplicate bring up in
here and I believe the last name here
was Toby Sykes
so Toby Sykes is the last names TOB why
that's why kts there is Toby and for
Toby I'm gonna bring back in this
element again and actually you know what
let's just skip let's just skip a name
it's not going to be so interesting if
we see name name name right and then
just graphics again because we start
with graphic name name name
traffic so let's put a graphic in right
here I'm not sure what that's going to
be yet so we'll extend this one here and
[Music]
and that's where we cut to black right
here so it's fine if it'd just get
perfect so there we go very basic setup
it's not so great yet but it will be
okay so the next thing I need to do is
bring in some texture and so I have
found this image that I absolutely love
and I'm gonna bring it down here and
this is my texture okay I can scale it
up it's there it doesn't need to be
anything that's like you know a lot of
times you say well you're scaling it up
200% that's gonna look terrible but
remember we're going for like a
futuristic glitchy kind of look and in
an analogue look and it doesn't need to
look perfect right it just needs to be
there needs to add something to our
overall design which that's what this is
so I'm just gonna leave it at this point
underneath everything and there it is
okay I'm also gonna bring in a piece of
footage to fill in this spot here and I
want this to be some code and something
else so there's a lot of different ways
you can create code you could create
hack over hacker text if you want to
call it that you could do something like
I could create a new solid here and call
this hacker text if you've got a plug-in
called universe from red giant let's see
here where we at hacker text okay
there's hacker text or screen text
there's all types of different text
elements you could build here if I solo
this layer hit B and in to preview just
this area here where let's see if we got
any hacker text going on here so I could
do something where I you know simply
select a free set open up my presets
here and it's gonna load up and I'm
gonna select a preset oh here's a bunch
of presets and I could just randomly
select let's say this first one here and
apply it and I believe it's applied
there
turn up to scroll rate you know
reposition I said there's a there's a
thousand different ways you can make
hacker text this is just something red
giants recently put in that's pretty
cool
make it scroll even faster wants to be
really just crazy and then text settings
I don't know let's just say sure those
all work so there are some random texts
you can also do things where you could
go to like a website right so I've got a
website pulled up here called hacker
type net and I've done this before where
you just start typing right and I could
screen capture this so I could use a
program like ScreenFlow or Camtasia you
can screen capture doing all this random
code recording this and then you bring
that recording back into After Effects
and you've got like some random code so
I start recording here so because of the
scrolls you know the text is moving
upwards it's more interesting we
simulated that with our hacker text here
but that's a different way you can do it
so to make it even more in check out
probably duplicate this I would probably
I don't know offset this so it's in a
different position maybe somewhere like
here you know something like that and if
I preview this and turn off the audio
you're gonna see we've got some
interesting hacker text going on here
that's pretty cool so I'm bring in one
more element and this element is called
grid well five this is from a product
packed I'm not trying to get you to buy
my product pack this is something I made
called radical retro elements which I'm
really proud of and it's just a pack
with all these different elements to it
and it has a lot of really interesting
textures right so this is like this is
like I said called grid wall five
there's a bunch of different grid walls
and we can do some like this and overlay
it and you know maybe set it to
something like screen
and now we've got this hacker text going
on with this stuff corner so already you
know it's very interesting to see this
right you're starting to see what I'm
trying to do I'm starting to layer some
elements up and make image more
interesting somewhat unsolo these and
now I've got this background which it's
hard to see this but once we get a few
more things going you're gonna see where
I'm going with this and I'm gonna wrap
this video up here in just a minute but
before I do let's go ahead and just
reverse this so let's move the hacker
text and grid wall background up and
let's move the second grid of texts Gina
black is here we go there so I'm gonna
hit in the beginning hit B turn my audio
back on I'm just gonna watch this back
and see how things look I mean I know
this does not look interesting at all
yet but it will
[Music]
so the only thing I hear is that I want
this cut to black to happen a little bit
later about here with this last snare so
I'll extend this scene play it again
[Music]
okay and that's gonna do it for this
video I promise you you're probably
saying okay this looks terrible how did
he get from what I see now to this and
what you're seeing here that's
everything that we just did that's the
base right we've got the base in there
so now the next thing we're do is the
next video we're gonna move in and we're
gonna start adding some motion to this
we're gonna add some 3d cameras to bring
the motion make the motion really come
alive we're also gonna add some lights
and some shadows and some things like
that to give it a little bit more depth
right to make it a little bit more
interesting to see we've got the baked
the basic building blocks of our design
in there now we need to start adding
some some basic motion blocks and basic
a camera motion and some lighting to
really bring this thing to life so
that's coming up in the next video it's
coming to you real soon in the next few
days until then I want you to leave me a
comment below or send me an email
hello at motion science TV let me know
what you think let me know if you have a
question let me know what what is it
that you're wondering about about the
process we're moving through let me help
answer those questions for you and I can
do that I'm in some of the next videos
so stay tuned for the next video again
I'm Cameron with motion science I'm so
excited to have you here
I'm excited to have you watch the next
several videos that are coming out to
show you how to go from idea to
execution until then leave me a comment
below shoot me an email let me know what
you think
you